Steve Irwin
He was a force of nature - the quintessential
Aussie outdoorsmen.
With his wicked sense of humor and his insatiable
passion for wildlife, Steve Irwin - the crocodile
hunter - became a worldwide celebrity.
He shone a spotlight on man’s mismanagement
of our natural resources and championed the
plight of the planet’s most vulnerable inhabitants
- the animals.
But Steve was also a daredevil - constantly
pushing the limits in his interactions with
the wild.
Then, in a tragic moment, he was gone, taken
from us far too soon.
In this Biographics we get to grips with the
Crocodile Hunter from Down Under, Steve Irwin.
The Wilderness Child
Stephen Robert Irwin was born on February
22nd, 1962 in Melbourne, Australia.
Both of his parents were passionate about
wildlife.
His father, Bob, was a plumber, but he was
also a keen amatuer herpetologist who studied
amphibians, while mother Lyn was a wildlife
rehabilitator.
When Steve was just a few years old the family
moved to Queensland, where Bob and and Lyn
opened the Queensland Reptile and Fauna Park.
Steve, therefore, grew up around animals and
was soon put to work at the park.
He would clean out the cages and feed the
crocodiles and lizards.
By the age of six, he was completely accustomed
to being around creatures that most children
would be terrified of.
His whole existence was surrounded by wildlife,
from crocodiles to kangaroos and koalas.
The Irwin’s developed their Reptile park
from nothing.
They spent the first couple of years living
in a small caravan as they slowly added to
their animal inventory.
The first snakes they put on display were
ones that Bob and Steve captured while out
fishing.
Meanwhile Lyn was busy rehabilitating orphaned
joeys, kangaroos, koalas, wombats, snakes
and crays.
At the same time, she was raising three children
of her own.
Steve proved to be a mischievous child, who
was always testing the patience of his father.
He would constantly go missing, ony to be
discovered down at the local creek chasing
lizards.
Yet, he wasn’t being rebellious.
He wanted to find venomous snakes and lizards
so that he could show them to his dad and
win his approval.
But rather than making his father proud, Steve’s
constant wanderings left Bob frustrated.
They boy was hyperactive, never sitting still.
From the age of two, he developed a love of,
and skill for, climbing trees.
So, the first thing that his family members
would do when he went missing was to look
up.
On the way to school, if he saw a dead reptile
lying on the road, Steve would make his mother
stop so that he could get out and investigate.
When he was six years old, he got the best
present he could have wished for - a twelve
foot long python.
Steve absolutely adored his new best friend.
At school, Steve was considered a bit of an
oddity by his peers.
He wasn’t into the normal boy things, like
bicycles, sport and skateboards.
He spent his lunchtimes wandering around the
school yard looking for birds, lizards and
any other creatures he could find.
After a while, other kids got involved, looking
to Steve as the local expert on all things
related to wildlife.
Bob Irwin was a hero and a mentor to his son.
He was a wildlife innovator who was at the
cutting edge of animal husbandry.
With the Wildlife Park established with a
good supply of smaller reptiles and animals,
Bob decided it was time to add a couple of
crocodiles.
He took nine year old Steve with him on his
first crocodile hunt.
As expected, the boy was extremely active
and it was all his dad could do to keep him
in the boat.
When a croc was sighted, Steve would want
to be the first one to grab it.
He was positioned at the front of the boat
with the spotlight while his father was operating
the outboard motor.
As they got close, Steve fixed his gaze on
the eyes of what he thought was a small croc.
The he pounced out of the boat and into the
water, grabbing it by the neck.
But the boy hadn’t realized how large this
crocodile was.
It was, in fact about the same size as him
- and quite a bit stronger.
The boy and the croc struggled for a while.
When it became clear to Bob that his son was
getting the worst of the encounter, he reached
his arm into the water and scooped up both
of them, scooping the boy and the croc into
the boat and pinning the animal down with
his body.
Recovering quickly, Steve took over the job
of holding down the croc, a huge smile on
his face - it was the proudest moment of his
life so far.
The Crocodile Hunter
In the early ‘70’s reports of crocodiles
attacking people were becoming more frequent
around Australia.
As the stock of crocodiles at the Reptile
Park grew, Bob decided to involve himself
in attempts to resolve the conflicts between
crocodiles and humans.
He joined the East Coast Crocodile Management
Program and he and Steve threw themselves
into the task of capturing and relocating
crocs from areas where there was potential
for a nasty encounter with humans.
It was extremely dangerous and exciting work
and Steve excelled at it.
He had a natural gift for, not only locating
the crocs, but also for capturing them.
He would get absolutely focused on catching
a crocodile, as if he were entering into one-on-one
combat with it.
Once the croc was secured and subdued in his
net, he would get a huge adrenaline rush,
which would make him keen for the next encounter.
By the time he was in his late teens, Steve
was living in the bush for extended periods
of time, camping out under the stars and spending
days at a time in pursuit of a single croc.
He had to live off the land and the water,
honing his bush skills while developing the
mystique of the crocodile hunter.
It was gruelling, physically demanding work
- and most of the time Steve was on his own.
He was young, fit, keen and innovative.
Steve became the most successful crocodile
hunter in the land.
With his growing reputation came a degree
of complacency.
He began to feel that he could do anything.
On one occasion he got a croc back to his
camp, ready to put into a crate but he had
neglected to secure the animal’s mouth.
Not realizing this, Steve let the croc out
of its net as he prepared the crate.
Then, with his back turned, the croc attacked,
snapping its huge jaws around his leg.
Fortunately, Steve got out of the situation
with nothing but a few holes in his foot.
On another occasion, Bob went up into northern
Queensland in search of an infamous croc known
as ‘Aggro.’
This creature would pop it’s head out of
the water right next to boats, horrifying
the locals.
Bob’s goal was to locate the beast and set
up a marker so that his son could follow up
and execute the capture.
Bob located the croc easily and made a mark
in an overhanging tree so that Steve would
know where to set the trap.
Yet, from the moment that he went in, Steve
could feel that ‘Aggro’ was stalking him.
As he was setting the trap something bumped
into his boat and his dog began barking.
Steve quickly set the trap and then left.
Now it was a matter of watching and waiting.
On the third day, Steve headed for the site
only to discover that the trap was completely
submerged under water.
The bait had been taken and the trap had gone
off.
Steve brought his boat close and grabbed hold
of the net, ready to drag the captured croc
on deck.
Suddenly there was a massive upheaval as the
croc smashed into the boat from under the
water.
A stunned Steve managed to maintain his grip
on the net, but then another blow rocked the
boat, and then another.
But Steve held on and began dragging the net
in.
Finally he managed to get the tail on board.
But then the entire body of the croc catapulted
out of the water and into the air coming down
beside Steve in the boat.
The man and his dog immediately jumped into
the water.
Steve now grabbed whatever he could - branches,
ropes, mud and threw it on top of the violently
thrashing crocodile.
The ideal thing would have been to blindfold
the animal, but that was out of the question.
Steve then jumped into the boat and onto the
back of the croc.
He threw more netting over the beast, trying
to cover its eyes.
Then he fired up the outboard motor and started
for shore.
All the way back the crocodile fought so violently
that Steve was convinced the boat was about
to split apart.
Steve finally got the one ton crocodile secured
and restrained at his camp.
His next problem was how to move it.
He decided to go back to a local farm and
recruit some helpers.
But when the cane farmers saw the size of
‘Aggro’ they refused to get out of their
boat.
Steve had to resort to getting a front end
loader to shift the croc.
It was experiences like these that turned
Steve into a local legend.
Yet the man himself had mixed feelings.
He felt regret that he had had to remove Aggro,
the king of that land, from his natural environment.
Australia Zoo
By 1990 Steve had recaptured more than a hundred
crocs.
Some of them were kept at the Reptile Park
while the majority were released into the
wild.
In 1991, Bob and Lyn decided that Steve had
come of age and was ready to take full control
of the park.
Steve’s goal was to make his parents proud
and he knew he would do it by turning the
park into the greatest wildlife facilities
on the face of the earth.
His first step was to rename the park ‘Australia
Zoo.’ he then threw himself into creating
the most exciting, educational and entertaining
wildlife experience that zoo visitors would
ever experience.
The highlight was the crocodile show where
Steve would be right up close and personal
with crocs, totally in control and showing
no fear.
He would tell the crowds what passionate and
loving animals they were.
With his huge personality and boundless energy
he quickly won over the public and attendance
figures went through the roof.
Terri
In 1991, among the tens of thousands of visitors
to Australia Zoo was Terri Raines, a veterinarian
and animal lover from the United States.
She was looking for a place to relocate cougars
that had been used in the entertainment industry.
She was drawn to the crocodile demonstration
and the fast talking Aussie who was in with
the deadly creatures.
Terri wrote down her immediate impressions
of Steve . . .
I thought there was no-one like this anywhere
in the world.
He sounded like an environmental Tarzan, a
larger-than life superhero guy.
Steve managed to catch sight of Terri in the
crowd and, according to him it was love at
first sight.
The two kindred spirits were engaged four
months after that first encounter.
They married in Eugene, Oregon, Terri’s
home town, on June 4th, 1992.
Their honeymoon was spent hunting crocodiles
in Northern Queensland.
To say that Terri was out of her element on
this trip was an understatement.
She had never been into the harsh Australian
outback and she had definitely never been
on a croc hunt before.
But.
trusting implicitly in the man that she referred
to as her ‘prince’, she threw herself
into the experience.
Accompanying the Irwin’s on their honeymoon
adventure was Steve’s friend, John Stainton.
Stainton filmed the action of the croc hunt
and other adventures, including Terri’s
first encounter with a six foot long black
snake.
This footage became the first episode of a
new Animal Planet TV show called The Crocodile
Hunter.
The series which featured both Steve and Terri
was so successful that a second, and then
a third, series were ordered.
It was a hit in over 130 countries, with hundreds
of millions of people embracing Steve’s
lovable, over the top Aussie personality.
His trademark catchphrase, ‘Crikey!’
became known the world over.
The final episode of series three was entitled
‘Steve’s Last Adventure’.
It followed him across the world as he embarked
upon adventures everywhere from the Himalayas,
to South Africa and China.
The Crocodile Hunter series allowed Steve
to take his conservation message to the world.
He viewed it as his life’s mission to work
tirelessly to save the world’s endangered
species.
As a result of his name recognition, he became
the front man for a number of media campaigns
and became a passionate ambassador for Australian
tourism.
Steve crusaded for wildlife preservation,
using his fame to bring the issue to public
consciousness.
In the late 90’s he also discovered a new
species of sea turtle and was at the forefront
of a campaign against animal poaching.
He also funded large nature reserves not just
in Australia, but also in Fiji, Vanuatu and
the United States.
Irwin’s TV series fame led to more television
and even some movie work.
He appeared in 2001’s Dr. Dolittle 2 as
himself and then starred in The Crocodile
Hunter; Collision Course the following year.
In 2006, he provided the voice for an elephant
seal named Trev in the movie Happy Feet.
The money that Steve made from his TV and
movie appearances was poured into building
new exhibits for Australia Zoo and for funding
conservation projects.
The zoo was designed as an environmental park,
with the comfort of the animals the foremost
concern.
Fences and cages would only be used when absolutely
necessary.
The staff at the zoo grew to about 50 and
the area expanded to eventually take up 100
acres.
The Zoo won the award for Best Australian
tourist attraction in 2003-4.
In 2004 the Australian Animal Hospital was
opened right next to the zoo.
The hospital cares for around 6,000 animals
each year.
In 2006, Australia Zoo Retail won the Australian
Tourism Retailing Award.
A Family Man
Steve and Terri had two children together,
Bindi, born in 1998, and Robert, in 2003.
Bindi’s birth was filmed and shown on TV
for the Crocodile Hunter series.
Steve had been filming for the show when he
got the call that Terri’s waters had broken.
He turned up at the hospital two hours later
with a complete film crew in tow.
Terri was surprised but, as was her nature,
took it all in her stride.
They were both surprised, but delighted, that
the baby was a girl.
Steve knew instantly what the name was going
to be - Bindi Sue, after his favorite croc
and his favorite dog.
Steve was the self proclaimed proudest father
on the face of the earth.
He and Bindi bonded instantly, becoming virtually
inseparable.
She went on her first wildlife documentary
shoot at just six days old.
Bindi would grow up in the international spotlight,
starring in her own show, Bindi: Jungle Girl
when she was eight years old.
Although the first series aired the year after
Steve’s passing, it was shot before he died
and so he featured in several episodes.
Criticism and Praise
November of 2003 found Steve filming a documentary
off the coast of Baja California Peninsula
in Mexico about sea lions.
A report came through the boat’s radio that
a pair of scuba divers were missing in the
area.
Steve immediately shut down filming and he
and his team joined the search.
The next day, members of his crew found one
of the divers clinging to a rocky cliff edge.
Steve and another rescuer brought the man
back to their boat.
The other man’s body was located a short
time later.
In early 2004, Steve made the news for the
wrong reasons when video was shown of him
feeding a chicken carcass to a twelve and
a half foot saltwater crocodile while holding
his one month old son, Robert.
Child welfare and animals rights groups alike
condemned the action, with some referring
to it as child abuse.
Both Steve and Terri contended that he had
full control over the situation, Nevertheless,
Steve did apologize, doing so on American
channel NBC.
The incident prompted the Queensland Government
to enact a law stating that no untrained persons
or children were allowed inside a crocodile
enclosure.
Steve was also criticized for his conservation
views, which some viewed as overly simplistic
and weighted towards tourism.
The Sydney Morning Herald wrote that his message
boiled down to ‘eating roos and crocs is
bad for tourism, and therefore more cruel
than eating other animals.’
There were, however, other industry experts
were poured praise upon Irwin and the work
that he had done to raise the public's awareness
of conservation issues.
Mark Townsend, the CEO of Queensland's RSPCA
called him a ‘modern day Noah,’ while
a Canadian environmentalist remarked after
Steves’ passing.
. .
"humanity will not protect that which we fear
or do not understand.
Steve Irwin helped us understand those things
that many people thought were a nuisance at
best, a horror at worst.
That made him a great educator and conservationist.”
Steve’s own conservation mentor was British
conservationist and film-maker Sir David Attenborough.
A month after Steve’s death, Terri Irwin
presented Attenborough with a Lifetime Achievement
Award.
In his acceptance speech, Sir David praised
Steve, saying that he “taught [people] how
wonderful and exciting nature was, and he
was a born communicator.”
Death & Legacy
Throughout his 44 years, Steve had taken on
and defeated many of the most dangerous creatures
on the planet.
It was ironic then, that the animal that would
get the better of him was a normally tranquil
fish.
On September 4th, 2006, he was filming off
Australia’s Great Barrier Reef for a documentary
to be called Ocean’s Deadliest.
The weather had been bad for three days, so
Steve had been sitting around with little
to do but wait for the weather to improve.
Today he decided to a do a bit of snorkelling
in the shallow waters which could be filmed
for his daughter Bindi’s new TV show.
He got down into the water, which was only
at chest height.
Seeing a large blue Bull Stingray, he came
over top of it in order to film it as it swam
away.
However, just as he hovered above it, the
stingray thrust up its tail and began stabbing
it upward.
A barb was shot directly into Steve’s chest.
He immediately pulled it out and rose to the
top and struggled to get back onto the boat.
The crew administered CPR and then rushed
him to the nearest hospital.
He was announced dead on arrival.
Steve Irwin’s legacy lives on through his
wife Terri and his children, Bindi and Robert.
These three Wildlife Warriors continue to
run Australia Zoo and to honor the memory
of this truly amazing man.